me
[Applause]
i clear so many tracks all the time
want to know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man hmm I love
this burger so delicious well the best
burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher
[Music]
space invasion
mccartey
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to let miss you today we have no idea
what threats are out there
we can't do this alone
I'm not what you think I am
the world is on the brink I'm sorry I
didn't stop it sooner you're always
sorry Charles and there's always a
speech and nobody cares
they're still
don't do this
they're right to fear me
I've seen evil
I'm looking at it now
[Applause]
do you know a mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous and adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]